hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar applications of
targeted NGS panels for clinical
research primary immunodeficiency
diseases and Judy Oracle's lab roots and
I'll be moderating the session today's
educational web seminars presented by
lab group leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars and bouncing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific thermo fisher is a world
leader and serving client whose mission
is to enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer the clinical
sequencing division of thermo fisher
scientific offers solutions for
next-generation sequencing under the Ion
Torrent brands of products which include
ion emphasis panels I on s5 sequencers
and I on reporters software for more
information please visit www tech comm
/i on torrentz let's get started here
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CT button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits you can post
questions to the speakers during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind did you so simply type them in the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green doing a button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or you
can report your problem by clicking on
the green two and a button at lower left
I now present today's speakers Janet
Chow md and rain Bainter dr. Chow is an
assistant professor of pediatrics at
Harvard Medical School and an allergy
immunology stat Boston Children's
Hospital's her research focuses on the
genetic and molecular mechanisms
underlying human primary
immunodeficiencies with an emphasis on
identifying rational targeted approaches
for immunomodulation
dr. childs experiences a Clinical
Immunology stripes or search from our
precise and rapid ways of understanding
immune dysregulation she received her MD
from Harvard Medical School and
completed a residency in pediatrics and
a fellowship in allergy and immunology
both at Boston Children's Hospital Wayne
painter is a research technologist at
Boston Children's Hospital his expertise
encompasses the application of genetic
approaches in the study of human immune
disorders functional analysis of the
immune system and characterization of
murine models of human disease in his
current world wing is leading the
targeted next-generation sequencing
initiative in the jahaal laboratory at
Boston Children's Hospital he graduated
from selves a routine university with a
BS in biology and minor in chemistry dr.
shell will now begin her presentation
thank you Judy so today I'm going to
discuss applications of targeted
next-generation DNA sequencing to pry
memory no deficiency research as most of
you know primary immunodeficiencies are
genetic diseases that impair the immune
system resulting in breaches of host
immunity that normally is responsible
for immune surveillance until tolerance
as a result individuals with primary
immunodeficiencies developed severe
life-threatening infections autoimmunity
and or malignancy primary deficiencies
occur globally although they are rare
diseases they are most common in areas
with high rates of consanguinity due to
founder effects and the predominance of
autosomal recessive primary no
deficiencies however these diseases do
occur through all modes of inheritance
are in fat and are found in all
populations of globally so we study
these diseases truly to identify novel
mechanisms of host immunity because
knowledge of genetic ideologies
underlying primary immunodeficiencies
has defined and leveraged cancer
research tools the development of
immunomodulatory agents and studies of
inflammation and self tolerance
so in going about this research there
are three main strategic challenges the
first is genetic diversity and there are
approximately 10,000 genes expressed in
the immune system and of these about 300
mono genetic causes of primary the
primary immunodeficiencies are known
with about 10 to 15 new genetic causes
identified annually so the rapidly
moving field the second strategic
challenge is the phenotypic variability
in that one disease may have many
different phenotypes or conversely
deleterious variants in different genes
can result in similar phenotypes so the
genotype phenotype correlations can be
difficult to predict and thirdly there
is a level of technical complexity
because the biologic assays of the
immune system are essential for
characterizing these disorders but these
assays are highly specialized they
require viable cells from study
participants and they are costly due to
read expertise as necessary to conduct
them so I'm going to first give you an
overview about how we approach the study
of these disorders and how we identify
these mechanisms and then I'll delve
into applications in our own research
and I have these three main approaches
of categories almost historically the
first being educated guesses which is
the longest-standing approach where one
uses the knowledge of immunologic and
signaling pathways to predict and define
what a new primary no deficiency might
be caused by so the advantages of this
approach is that primarily it builds
logically on existing foundations of
knowledge and methodology but it's very
challenging to identify entirely novel
pathways using this approach because of
course it's built on what's already
known the second approach that's widely
use now are similarities to mouse models
of disease so the main advantage of this
approach is that the mouse models show
us the in vivo relevance of candidate
genes and effects of various variants
however as we all know my son
men and so there's differences between
the mirin and human phenotypes and it
may be due to the species differences or
the environmental differences or even
epigenetic differences and thirdly the
most new and perhaps the most widely
used now are the unbiased genetic
approaches for identifying mechanisms of
P IDs so the main advantage of this
approach is that one can discover truly
novel causes of PID s using this
unbiased approach the disadvantage is
that there is a lot of data that's
generated which is certainly manageable
but more pertinently these approaches
give very little information about the
true biologic effect though the variant
so the way we conduct our research is
through an international consortium for
immune immune deficiency which is
spearheaded by race jihad with chief of
the division at Boston Children's
immunology and it incorporates a network
of collaborators from 19 countries in
Europe the Middle East northern Africa
North and South America so it's really a
global collaboration and we have an
annual study subject enrollment of over
150 individuals per year with
immunodeficiencies phenotypes and the
hope of this consortium is at Boston
Children's where we have a group of six
people with collective expertise in
basic and clinical immunology genomics
in molecular and cellular biology and I
would say that you know this makes a
part of our work but not wholly and so
in our aim to define novel genetic and
molecular mechanisms underlying primary
no deficiencies speed and throughput are
really key factors and how we do our
research so the repertoire of tools that
we use encompass three main groups which
basically fall into those three
approaches that I previously discussed
the first involves in vvill models where
you start with the subject study
subjects phenotypic data and one may
close and recapitulate the human disease
by making a knockin or knockout mouse
model of that phenotype once the
causative variant is known
the second main group of tools are I
call them functional assays or biologic
assays and broadly speaking baby can be
classified in terms of studies that look
approaching expression seller or
functioning and molecular signaling
obviously these are extremely broad and
within each category there's a plethora
of specific techniques and thirdly are
the genomic technologies which include
microarrays Sanger sequencing targeted
next-gen sequencing and whole exome and
genome sequencing so it in categorizing
these tools you can see that the in vivo
models in the functional assays share
the strengths and the weaknesses the
strengths being that they are essential
for the characterization and
understanding and mechanisms underlying
these disorders but the weakness is that
it will not identify the specific
genetic variant that underlies this
disease on the other hand genomic
technologies complement the other two
approaches in the sense that the genomic
approach will identify the causative
variant but provides no or very little
information about the biologic effects
of the variants so for this reason we
incorporate all three approaches and all
of these tools in our search for
mechanisms that underlie primary
immunodeficiencies so I'm going to show
you how we have done our research both
in the past which did not involve
targeted next-gen sequencing and in the
present which does so previously we
would have recruitment of study subjects
with PID phenotypes and for each study
subject there would be at least a two to
four week period of phenotypic
investigation this includes functional
assays Sanger sequencing of candidate
genes and if there was no candidate gene
that was identified we would then
outsource the whole exome or whole
genome sequencing and that would take at
least two to three months sometimes
longer depending on how complex the
analysis was and if we were able to find
a candidate variant we would proceed
then onwards to the mechanistic
investigation so this is really the work
that proves the biologic effective
candidate variant and we often will
recapitulate the human disease in a
mouse model and you can see the length
of time is really quite longer for the
mechanistic investigation Lessing
somewhere up to three or sometimes
longer years using this approach we
sequenced over a hundred study subjects
using whole exome or whole genome and
our yield of variants that we found to
be a positive of the phenotype was about
fifty five percent so this is greater
than what's been published in some of
the large more recent studies in the New
England Journal and in JAMA about the
use of whole exome sequencing and
finding genetic variants those studies
published a percentage of about
twenty-five percent yield and I would
say our increased yield is partly in due
to the fact that we focus on a specific
disease type that is immunodeficiencies
of course and also we are able to
incorporate more than to just genetic
assays so the phenotypes and the
functional assays are important in
really characterizing event letting us
understand the phenotype very thoroughly
before we start analyzing the whole
exome or whole genome data so the
lessons we learned from that approach
actually was that the majority of
subjects had an identified ideology
which was really just an atypical
phenotype due to a deleterious mutation
in the gene that was already known to be
associated with immunodeficiency so all
these study subjects were screened by a
senior immunologists and even with that
initial screening process we had
unexpected phenotypes and we found that
the personal a family history of
life-threatening infections was the only
variable that was significantly
associated with identification of a
causative variant and that other factors
such as consanguinity gender age
assistant ansa and age at the time of
the study enrollment did not increase
the odds of identifying the causative
variants so we found that interesting
because it showed us that this approach
could be used beyond the
witness populations and could really be
used in a more global approach but that
also showed us that because most of the
variants were found in known teams that
we were spending a lot of our resources
and our time finding things that were
already known and we needed a better and
a fastest recruitment methods the
strength of this approach found that you
know it's mechanistically detailed and
we did have proven ability to identify
novel ideologies of coming reno
deficiencies about ten percent of the
study subjects had a novel cause of
disease that had not been previously
described in any of the medical
literature the drawbacks as I mentioned
her that it was time consuming on the
cost so based on this we really wanted
to find an approach that would let us
focus the bulk of our resources on new
biology and new mechanisms so with that
aim we incorporated a targeting targeted
next-gen sequencing approach using the
ims 5 system so you can see that the
main difference in this approach here
highlighted blue is that after study
recruitment all subjects undergo genetic
screening using this targeted next-gen
panel the panel we use is called the
primary me no deficiency panel that's
provided by thermo Fisher and micro
speaker with Boehner will go into the
technical details of the panel use and
the metrics and the data outputs but in
terms of the big picture we basically
have three outcomes either after
screening with the panel we identify a
clear etiology a clear causative variant
of the study is complete no more
resources spent on a known gene then
there's also possible variants or there
may be several of them and so then we
will then move on to mechanistic studies
to determine which if any of those
causes of variance would be associated
with the phenotype and finally the most
interesting of course would be those
that have no known ideology that is
there were no variants that were found
on the pre-screening and those study
subjects undergo whole exome and whole
genome and meka
stick studies so you can see that by
triaging of the study subjects using the
targeted panel that we're able to focus
more about resources on the cases that
have unknown etiology and i will show
you just an overview of the outcomes of
how that increased our speed so using
this approach for the past 11 and a half
months we have actually found an
increased yield of causative variance so
using this approach we've had a yield of
about eighty percent compared to
fifty-five percent which we had
previously using our initial whole exome
approach part of this may be due to the
fact that we were able to achieve higher
coverage at lower cost using a targeted
panel and it is much easier using this
to target panel to identify large exonic
deletions then combing through the whole
exome copy number variation data our
throughput has increased tremendously by
seven fold so we're able to process at
least 70 samples per month and will
probably increase a ton goes on versus
about 10 samples per month using our old
methods with this higher throughput and
with the targeted panel there's a lower
cost for samples with mutations in known
PID genes that's because the cost of the
panel itself is far cheaper and far less
time-consuming than doing all of the
functional assays and the Sanger
sequencing that we had done manually
previously so this really enables us to
focus our resources on research samples
with potentially novel mechanisms of
primary immunodeficiency in terms of
logistics it's much easier because DNA
is the starting material and there's a
very small amount only ten milligrams
that's needed and certainly this is much
easier to ascend internationally than
viable cells and from our experience
it's way more detail it's quite simple
to establish this in-house compared to
setting up whole exome sequencing um
in-house
so in terms of the drawbacks there is a
larger upfront costs for the s5 system I
and chef of course then outsourcing the
exomes on a per sample basis but
cumulatively the cost per sample will be
less using the new approach that
incorporates targeted sequencing it's
just that any technology will require an
initial outlay of funds there is a short
training and learning curve that we will
discuss and then finally the last
drawback is not specific just to
targeted end to it targeted next-gen
sequencing but really to all genomic
studies in the sense that they will
never replace mechanistic studies for
functional characterization or for whole
exome sequencing for identification of
novel genetic causes of immune
deficiency so I'm going to present just
two short case studies and the purpose
of this case studies is really to show
you some real metrics about the
differences in our old approach versus
in a new approach so the first study
subject is a 17 year old woman with a
history of intermittent neutropenia and
common variable immunodeficiency which
is the most common immunodeficiency
worldwide it is largely attributed to
defects in the humoral system so
immunoglobulins secretion and b cells
function but the specific genetic causes
of cvid are very few compared to the
number of piece of individuals who do
have this disorder this particular study
subject had a history of sepsis
disseminated intravascular coagulation
and necrotizing fasciitis and
unfortunately ultimately died from an
inflammatory episode thought to be
macrophage activation syndrome so is a
very severe phenotype using our old
approach using a functional approach we
would have done flow cytometry 40 B&K
memory b cells autoreactive b cells b
cell proliferation and in vitro
immunoglobulins secretion from b cells
and that's the starting panel and that
would have taken as you can see about
three weeks of work and from a genetic
perspective
as I mentioned the majority of
individuals with common variable
immunodeficiency have no identified
genetic etiology although there are at
least 12 known genetic causes of cvid
like phenotypes so send your sequencing
all the excellence for all those
possible genes which thought would
obviously have been even more
time-consuming and costly so running
this subject study subjects through the
NGS panel we identified a homozygous 7
base pair deletion in the genes CEC r1
which was a French frameshift leading to
a stop this gene encodes a DA to which
catalyzes the deamination of adenosine
and two prime deoxyadenosine to ina seen
in the deoxy I Nazim and it's released
by macrophages monocytes and dendritic
cells so ATA tu has been described but
largely it's been known to result in
early on fistrick and vasculopathy in
most although not all cases and combing
through the literature a small
percentage about fifteen percent or less
of the reports of this already rare
disease have hypo gamma globulin emia
and decreased memory b cells so although
the mechanism driving this defective b
cell function are not known it's
increasingly becoming realized that this
disorder has a humoral component that
really resembles cvid and in zebrafish
models are shown also that this enzyme
is important for neutrophils development
and maintenance so the challenging
aspects of this case are that it really
isn't a typical features of a d8 to
deficiency the study subject had no
vasculopathy early onset stroke and the
predominant feature was one that's found
in only a minority of patient which is
cvid but you can tell that based on the
severity of the mutation that is a
frameshift and a stop that this would be
the most likely genetic cause of the
disorder and the other thing is that
since the patient had passed away there
wasn't any further clinical research
material from her and so the study
wouldn't have been able to be done using
a functional approach
so what this was able to show us is that
we were able to find in a typical
phenotype of what is a known disease but
also to diverge as I've mentioned before
more of our resources to new biology and
in the second case i'm going to show you
is also another case of common variable
immunodeficiency in a 12 year old male
with a history of refractory pneumonia
and bronchiectasis he had a history of
reefs of a recent interstitial pneumonia
due to possible viral etiology so that
suggests that perhaps there might be a
defect in his t-cell function he also
had pancytopenia suggestive of
myelodysplastic syndrome and had mono so
me 7 that was found and was able to
receive the BCG or the TB vaccine which
is a live vaccine without any
complications which in contrast to his
long as you suggest that maybe he does
in fact have impacted t-cell function so
the difficulty of this case is that that
phenotype is not well defined it's hard
to tell whether this is truly cvid like
or whether it's more of a combined
immunodeficiency with defective T cell
function so again using our old
functional approach we would have had
the flow cytometry proliferation
immunological globulin secretion and
lymphocyte proliferation all of which
would have taken again over three weeks
and the candidate lists when the
phenotype is undefined like this is vast
so it's virtually impossible to pick
genes to start saying your sequencing
and so running this patients through the
next-gen panel we were able to find a
homozygous missense mutation a da so
this is different from the previous ad a
this is a isoenzyme so this gene encodes
adenosine deaminase one instead of two
and this disorder is known to have a lot
of phenotypic variability classically it
does prevent presenta severe combined
immunodeficiency which is the most
severe immune deficiency with an absence
of bt and NK cells and early infancy
although a small portion about fifteen
percent will have later onset at six to
24 months of age and there are rare rare
cases of individuals with this from four
years of age to adult fit in terms of
their onset of present
asian this particular mutation has
actually been previously reported to be
disease-causing and has been associated
with delayed onset of symptoms in older
years so again this shows very atypical
features because this individual had a
very mild presentation and was able to
tolerate a live vaccine that typically
patients with a combined
immunodeficiency would not be able to
have without any symptoms so these two
case studies show two putative distinct
genetic etiologies of cvid and they show
how using the targeted panel really
expedites the work compared to the
original functional or Sanger sequencing
based approach in terms of identifying
mechanisms of primary immunodeficiency
and so in conclusion I just like to
emphasize of course that p IDs are very
heterogeneous and that's what makes the
field both interesting and challenging
and that there are so many genetic
causes and that they really require a
multidisciplinary approach that
incorporates genomic biologic and in
vivo models and that this approach may
be helpful in discovering new mechanisms
of host immunity in both non-consent
witness as well as inbred populations
and finally it's a lesson that we really
learned in changing our workflow is that
the targeted sequencing approach
significantly increased our throughput
and decrease the cost per sample which
permitted us to have a very sharp focus
of our resources on novel mechanisms and
biology and so I'd like to thank of
course the group as the division of
immunology that spearheaded by rice jeho
and you can see the members of the core
consortium team when being there
Michelle Mossad Craig Platt and Britney
Canada me as well as the collaborators
that refer to these specific cases to us
and then finally all of our
collaborators who are part of the
consortium thank you
thank you dr. Chow for your presentation
a poll question will appear on your
screen you may select an answer and then
close the poll question by clicking on
the X in the right corner and the
question is are you interested in
adopting the ion ampliphi primary immune
deficiency research tunnel or your
research and testing needs
and when the pole um concludes I will
then turn the presentation over to Wayne
beta
you
I think the poll has now concluded for
Wayne whenever you're ready for your
presentation please begin okay well
hello and thank you all for joining us
today as Judy said my name is Wayne
Bainter and I am a research technologist
at Boston Children's Hospital in the
division of immunology to complement
Janet's great talk on the applications
of targeted sequencing to the field of
primary immunodeficiencies I'm going to
present the highlights and practical
aspects of the ion s5 system before we
purchase the system we compared it to
other options and had many questions
about the real life workflow hands-on
procedures and data analysis that goes
into the system my talk today will
address all of these questions and
topics I know many of you are familiar
with NGS but for those of you that are
new to the world of NGS I will be giving
you an overview of these steps before
duck before delving into our
out-of-the-box experience with the ion
s5 system additionally since I'm going
to discuss the granular aspects of our
data I will also give a synopsis of the
technology used by this system our setup
utilizes the ion chef for automated
vibrated preparation template
preparation and chip loading this
instrument significantly significantly
reduces the amount of hands-on time and
variances that occur with manual library
preparation once we have a loaded chip
it is put on to the iOS 5 which then
performs the sequencing and subsequently
aligns the data and also performs
variant calling in this overview of the
sequencing process you see that the
first step in the sequencing process
begins with library preparation on the
ion chef we begin with eight samples of
DNA that undergo a targeted multiplex
PCR known as an amplitude reaction by
thermo Fisher this then amplifies the
264 jeans on the thermo Fisher PID v2
panel during this multiplex process each
sample is ligated with an adapter and
also a unique barcode which then allows
for each library fragment to be
recognized by the sequencer as a
specific sample once the amplification
is complete the libraries are purified
pooled and equalized at a concentration
of 100 pico molar
now that we have a pooled library we're
ready to begin template preparation
which also takes place on the Iron Chef
template preparation begins by binding
each library fragment onto a bead using
the adapter added during library
preparation once bound each fragment
undergoes clonal amplification being an
emulsion PCR this then fills the bead
with a unique one unique library
fragment the full bead is also known as
an eye on sphere particle or isp and
then this is then loaded onto a spy on
semiconductor chip which contains
billions of microwaves that each ISP
sits in a chip containing full ISPs of
all library fragments is then loaded
into the ion s5 sequencer the iOS 5 uses
a unique semiconductor technology which
utilizes the change in pH during
nucleotide incorporation to detect the
library sequence the s5 begins the
sequencing process by flowing single
nucleotide solutions over the chip when
a DNT p is incorporated to the leading
unpaired template nucleotide a hydrogen
ion is released in the pH within the
Micra well is then decreased that change
in pH is then detected button recorded
by the instrument after the float that
the first DNT p each well is washed out
in a new flow with the different DNT p
has started this process happens for
each of the four DNT PS for a total of
five hundred flows for the io NS five
system thermo fisher offers three
different semiconductor chips to
accommodate different coverage needs
each chip has different capacities for
read lengths ranging from anywhere from
three to five million reads on the ion
520 all the way to 60 to 80 million
reads on the ion 540 the right chip
depends on the number of amplicons in
your panel the number of samples and the
desired sequencing coverage that you
need for the for the eye on for the PID
v2 panel we're aiming for at least
ninety-five percent of all of our bases
with a minimum coverage of 20 x the the
PID v2 panel has approximately 5241
amplicons so it for a real life example
we found that running either eight
samples on 15 30 chip or 32 samples on
one
I on 540 chip will enable us to achieve
at least 20 X coverage on more than
ninety-five percent of our bases and we
found that sequencing more samples on a
larger chip is definitely more
cost-effective however this the smaller
chip is very useful for small runs that
need to be performed urgently now one of
the big questions that we had before
committing to the ion system was the
actual hands-on time required to run the
instrument now this chart here depicts
the time required to set up each step in
the ion system as you can see the bulk
of the hands-on time is actually
consumed by DNA isolation and
preparation and the ion system requires
40 minutes of hands-on time for only 16
samples in total each sample requires
approximately 51 minutes of pre-analysis
time of which about 45 minutes is
actually just DNA isolation you can see
that the use of the Iron Chef enables a
rapid loading go approach with minimal
time for library preparation another
important concern is subsequently the
hands-off time needed to run these
instruments here I show the time it
takes to run eight samples on 15 30 chip
as you can see the total hands-off time
is approximately 35 hours which enables
us to do other work while sequencing is
going on for our workflow I set up
library prep first thing in the morning
on the Iron Chef about 8 hours later I
remove the sample and load and prep the
machine for a template preparation which
then will run overnight the following
morning I will then load a chip into the
iOS 5 and it will be done sequencing in
about three hours and at that point the
data will then be uploaded onto the
cloud and analysis will then take place
we found that this approach enables a
rapid and convenient workflow I'm now
going to discuss the more granular
aspects of our data in our experience
with references to our results using the
iOS 5 system when we first purchased
this system we do not have any
experience with in-house next-generation
sequencing we had a three day training
with a field application specialist in a
bioinformatician and then that following
week were fully operational and ran our
first trip without any issues
I'm the one that's responsible for the
sample preparation machine operation and
data analysis and the data is then
cross-checked with my colleagues
consisting of physician scientists and
senior Sciences in just one month we've
already studied over 70 samples and
which as Janet mentioned is seven times
faster than a previous approach which
included functional assays and sanger
sequencing now I just want to give you a
quick idea of the run reports and the
data that's generated by the eye on
server1 sequencing is complete the run
report is a summary of run quality
metrics that go on in the chip now
here's an actual heat map of one of the
chips we ran the heat map indicates ISP
density and ship loading percentage thus
giving feedback on how well the chip is
loaded this is very important QC check
because it can indicate if any
mechanical issues with the chip occurred
during loading if the chips if the chip
is unevenly or incompletely voted the
coverage of the samples will be lower
than desired and you can see that
clearly on the heat map the run report
also generates ISP metric state metric
statistics and then this shows us some
of the most important information from
our sequencing run you can see that the
total reads of the run at the top which
for this trip was over 20 million reads
this number will vary depending on the
size of the chip used and this is on the
high end for a 530 chip just about 20
million reads another important
statistics shown is the clone allottee
of the library fragments this will tell
us how pure the ISP reads are because
the goal is to have one library fragment
/ bead now a run with local own ality or
high poly clonality indicates that the
beads have more than one library
fragment proved library for bead library
of sorry and we found that the clone
allottee of approximately sixty percent
generates a good data and complete data
lastly I want to highlight the final
library percentage this tells us what
percentage of breeds were low quality as
you can see from this run nine percent
of the chip was low quality and then it
can also show you the test fragments and
the dimers that occurred during the run
then this final slide of the run report
shows the average read blank and we
expect this to be around 200 base pairs
while having very few samples below that
too on your base pair mark as you can
see this run was spot-on with an average
read length of about 208 base pairs now
once sequencing data it has been aligned
to the reference sequence it is then
uploaded from the ion server to the ion
reporter now this software is easy to
use and annotates are variants the iron
reporter will then generate an Excel
spreadsheet which can then be easily
filtered and further annotated for our
use and as you can see here it will it
will generate an Excel spreadsheet that
will include the chromosome number and
position the temp the different types of
mutations the minor allelic frequency
the location of the variant like whether
it's an exonic or splice site or
intronic mutation the gene name the
codon sequence the excellent number
amino acid change polyphen and sift
scores which are very important to us
because they predict the effect of the
amino acid change and help us determine
if it's pathogenic or not as well as the
reference ranges to other databases
which is also very useful now for our
own data we use very few factors to
filter out the all the sequencing data
first I filter out using the minor
allelic frequency or the MAF for all the
variants which are less than one percent
in the population and this is because of
the rarity of primary unit deficiencies
in the human population we then focus on
the exonic and splice site mutations and
eliminate all synonymous mutations from
our initial analysis to prioritize those
variants which are most likely to be
deleterious and finally I filter based
on the poly pendants if score as I
mentioned because this helps us
determine the pathogenicity of the
variant now this chart here compares our
in-house generated data with data
generated by thermo Fisher for the PGM
and proton now thermo fisher generated
this performance data for the PGM proton
using the PID b2 panel which we also use
and I've compared the
it and I compared my results from five
different 530 chips to these runs and as
you can see our data from the from the
s5 system is definitely comparable to
the other predecessor instruments
however you can see that there's a the
coverage at 100 x is lower than both
machines now one thing to keep in mind
is that these sequencing runs on the ion
s5 were performed with eight samples per
chip as opposed to the two or six
samples on the PGM of proton now if we
were just to load two or six samples
like the PGM and proton we would
definitely have more coverage and
another way to increase the coverage
would be to run these eight samples on a
540 chip and this will allow for far
greater reads per run and one thing to
keep in mind too is that we didn't aim
we did not aim to maximize the number of
bases having a 100x coverage and this is
because our research focuses on germline
rather than somatic variants in our
experience so far we've had some minor
technical and mechanical issues but what
has been more important to us is not the
issues itself but more the resolutions
to these problems in the response and
expertise from thermo fisher's NGS group
has been absolutely superb and has been
superior to any experience we've had so
far in the lab we've had real time
support both in person and over the
phone their staff has been leading
leading us to complete resolutions to
all the questions and issues that we've
had and in closing I just want to
emphasize three aspects of our
experience this is the setup and
operation of this system was fully
functional after just three days of
training which is pretty amazing and
we've had excellent results so far which
is tremendously increased our pace of
our research that's Janet mentioned and
what I think sets thermo Fisher and iOS
5 system apart is the simplicity speed
and support offered by this whole group
and in closing I just like to thank dr.
Dre jihad the p.i in the chief of the
division of immunology at Boston
Children's Hospital dr. Janet Chow my
supervisor mentor and partner in science
and also I would like to thank dr.
Michelle Mossad Britney can Jamie and
dr. Craig plat for their assistance with
sample collection and core
nation thank you very much thank you
both for your presentations a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. Chow and Wayne
Bainter will answer as many questions as
time permits oh and you do we have a
second poll question for you here and so
the question is are you interested in
getting a quote for the eye on f5
sequencer and so if you will take a
moment to answer this question before we
jump into the Q&A that would be great
and a while while you are working on
that I will pose the first question and
the first question is how often do you
find two mutations simultaneously for
primary immune deficiency in
next-generation sequencing and how do
you decide which one is a causative
mutation so I think that's a great
question because primary no deficiencies
are classically considered monogenic
diseases that is one one mutation one
gene one disease but we what we are
finding is that increasingly there are
modified mutations or diseases that can
be caused by two simultaneous mutations
as this question poses in our experience
in terms of what I will consider two
distinct pathogenic variants that lead
to the disease phenotype it's definitely
in the minority I would say it's
probably in our experience about 5% or
less of the study subjects that we have
found but there are a few other modified
mutations so such as those in the FMS
gene that causes familial Mediterranean
fever gene that is more common in the
population in the middle
used and that I wouldn't consider as
much of a pathogenic more of a modifier
can accentuate the phenotype and so that
might be higher maybe closer to ten
percent if you include those kinds of
lesser modifier genes now how to sort
out which mutation is which causing
which disease or its contributions
really can be only done on a functional
approach so we either try to dissect the
two pathways by stimulating them in ways
where only one pathway and one mutation
will be evaluated versus the other the
other alternative approach is to
generate cell lines each having only one
mutation or the other and or one could
do it in a very expensive way with a
mouse model and the third approach is
actually to correct each mutation
individually and or together either
using lentiviral transduction or
transient transfection so the as I'd
mentioned before you know the
mechanistic part of it really has to be
done through a functional approach but
the targeted and the whole exome
approaches are what's needed to find all
of these mutations that are dual in
nature because each and every one of
them has been a surprise to us we've
actually never predicted a dual primary
immunodeficiency and we would never have
found it without a genomic approach and
our next question is for Wayne how are
you managing your sample information and
downstream data or using a laboratory
information management system um so
we're managing it just on our on the
hospital server and the we're actually
one of the best parts about this ion
system is we're making use of the ion
cloud that is provided to us so this has
really helped us organize and keep our
data straight okay the next one is for
Janet dr. Chow will you be updating the
panel to include more genes as more
genes or discovered that cause primary
immune deficiency
yes so that's definitely something that
we are going to do the way we decided to
do is to start first with the panel and
see how that worked out and because it's
worked so well we'll be updating
probably annually and in our discussions
with their own Fisher our understanding
is that you know the adding of the
custom jeans actually was quite doable
and not hard at all so given the pace of
the field and the fact that 10 to 15 new
genetic causes I would say are
identified each year we'll do an annual
update and then combine them in pools
with existing panel the next one is for
Wayne how many samples do you typically
run on each of the s5 chips and is it
more cost effective one second more cost
effective to dispatch and run samples on
the 540 yes I so usually I try to run 32
samples on the eye on 540 chip and as
you can imagine that takes about a week
to do all the library preparations for
that so I I try to do 32 on a 540 and
that is definitely more cost effective
but in some cases some samples are more
urgent so I can run just eight samples
on a 530 but if you're going for you
know down to the last penny definitely
running 32 samples on the 540 if there a
presence of t-cells and Zika affected
patients and if so is it possible on a
second term care and if it possible to
have enough to counteract the apoptosis
that is the generation of bone and brain
tissue in infants with micro
successfully with necessary adaptations
such as scaffold building self assembly
and polymerization and regenerative
biology sorry can you repeat the
question from the just in the first but
I couldn't I didn't understand I didn't
hear the first part sorry short is there
a presence of T cells in Zika affected
patients and if so
possible right all right so it seems to
me that this question is asking actually
about so everybody has T cells of course
and infection with any virus such as we
go or even the common cold or HIV
stimulates both the innate as well as
the adaptive immune system and so I
think this question is more one that's
looking at mechanisms of of host
immunity and perhaps asking why some
people get specific infections whether
it's Zika versus and do well and whereas
others may have a bad outcome and so the
current thinking really is that a host
response to a viral or any kind of
infection is of course reflected a
reflective of their the strength of
their immune system which is simplistic
but it's really the bottom line so what
we look for and using these panels and
the exomes and our approach are the
genetic causes why is it that person a
can get Zika virus and make us through
alright and person B may not make it at
all and end up dead and so it's a
complex question I think not specific
just to Zika but the answer being is
that you know of those ten thousand
genes there will be a constellation of a
few as we all have many mutations you
know that predispose some to having more
or worst viral infections because
perhaps their t-cell function isn't as
strong and dr. Sheldon excellence for
you to what was the variant yield of the
targeted panels of the first screen
versus out forcing whole exome
sequencing
so the yield for the first screen was
about fifty five percent and then that's
that's using outsourcing whole exome
sequencing and then using the targeted
panel is much higher it's about eighty
percent and so the difference in that
maybe the sample sizes aren't the same
yet because of course we've just been
doing the targeted sequencing for about
a month but that being said if that
holds true that difference I think the
part of it's because we're able to get
much greater depth of coverage using
targeted sequencing than whole exomes
just because it's much cheaper and we're
able to much more easily picked up large
exonic deletions and copy number
analysis of exomes is standard but it's
time consuming and sometimes tricky and
requires a bit of finesse for the
targeted panel is extremely easy to
analyze and to identify these exotic
deletions and we've certainly found some
study subjects who have had that as a
cause of their phenotype so I'd say that
the targeted panel itself has certain
advantages that we've found over exomes
certainly as a screening step it looks
like we have time for one more question
and it is where can I get information
about the ampliphi primary immune
deficiency panel okay you can go to
amplify calm and search for primary
immune deficiency to get panel details I
would like to once again thank dr. Janet
Chow and Wayne danger for their
presentations do you have any final
comments and now there is a pleasure to
be a part of this thank you very much
thank you very much for the opportunity
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions if we did not get
to your question today the sponsor and
the speakers will try to address them
after the presentation and we would like
to thank our sponsors thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be
you on demand through December 22nd 2016
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues and we have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye